bonsoir franck rassel merci d'être avec
nous sur rt france qu'elle est calé vous
êtes sur place 1 quelle est l'origine de
cette mutinerie ce aujourd'hui
oui je suis sur place donc déjà
premièrement aucun surveillant blessé
donc pour nous organiser dicale c'est le
principal aucun collègue de toucher au
niveau 2 des circonstances donc les
détenus ont cassé une grille palières
donc d'une coursive ont cassé les
caméras ont mis le feu à des matelas
l'incendié s'est propagé dans tout le
bâtiment et ont endommagé la toiture
voilà est-ce qu'on connaît le la raison
de cette mutinerie
non il n'y a pas de revendication le
centre détention d'ecrouves a reçu il ya
trois semaines suite à la mutinerie du
centre dépassons d'uzerche a reçu une
quinzaine de détenus y en a aucun qui
fait partie de cette contestation ce
soir c'est la période de confinement la
période de cette contamination du
coronavirus qui est compliqué à gérer
selon vous en quoi cette période de
confinement est elle compliquée
également pour le personnel
pénitentiaire pour le personnel
pénitentiaire c'est compliqué parce que
on a on en a toujours maintenant on a
des matches où on a dû gel on a tout ce
qu'il faut donc actuellement
l'administration
est-ce qu'il faut suite au référé
liberté qui avait demandé par
l'organisation syndicale nationale et fo
pénitentiaire
depuis donc la gestion de la détention
est différent qui a put parloir il y a
plus d'école il ya le sport est réduit à
une trentaine de détenus
on a d'exact est pareil c'est par par
groupe donc nous ça nous va nous changer
un peu la détention mais pour l'instant
ça se passait bien
moi j'étais sur place toute la journée
de mardi c'était calme nous vous voyez
un petit incident pas de quoi ça vient
peut déclencher quelque chose d'énorme
et malgré ces restrictions de sortie si
je puis dire dans les cours les tensions
son son talent sont pas énormes dans les
prisons actuellement sur le secteur
grand test s'est plutôt bien passé donc
maintenant on est dans la cinquième
semaine de confinement on espère que ça
va durer bon aujourd'hui il ya eu ce
qu'il ya eu à ecrouves
les équipes régionales d'intervention et
de sécurité sont sur place avec la
police pour maîtriser la situation il
sait en cours donc pour l'instant j'ai
pas plus d'infos à vous donner mais ça a
l'air de ce pacte est correctement alors
depuis le 16 mars dernier un dispositif
de réguliers harris de régulation
commune carcéral un été mise en place
sur tout le territoire dix mille détenus
qui ont été libérés ce que ça a donné
une bouffée d'air est ce que c'était
nécessaire selon vous de nous fédère
surtout sur les maisons d'arrêt une
essence détention n'était pas surpeuplée
dépend surpopulation et surtout les
maisons d'arrêt qui ont été soulagés par
toutes les libérations
franck rassel il y a beaucoup d'eau de
contamination du personnel pénitentiaire
a noté ou pas il ya une contamination
c'est comme pour la population
ça commence à aligner une paire de
collègues qui ont été touchés la plupart
sont guéris ou en voie de guérison et
sur le secteur lorrain pour l'instant il
n'y a pas de cas définis merci beaucoup
franck rassel d'avoir répondu à nos
questions sur rt france